bien sûr candidats vous présentera à
20h10 temps à leur présentera toute
l'équipe à sa façon à ne respectent
bonjour je connais une question comme
d'habitude exactement une question tout
de suite bonjour je m'appelle annie j'ai
vu que j'aime chez mr sortent un livre
jouer au théâtre
simple ce réchauffement climatique
peut-on considérer que c'est bientôt la
fin de notre civilisation mais je
comprends votre inquiétude chez ranimer
je pense pas c'est juste une coïncidence
de mauvaises nouvelles
maintenant il faut pas se voiler la face
le monde n'est pas en danger mais et
chroniqueur de cette émission si depuis
que jean michel foule les planches de la
comédie qu'au matin du vendredi au
samedi 19 heures le dimanche à 17 heures
tarif réduit possible les conditions de
travail dans tp sont beaucoup
détériorées
on est franchement on est à la limite du
harcèlement moral à ce que tapie la
semaine dernière jean michel terroriste
ses collègues avec son regard
d'intimidation ah oui c'est quoi je
parle pas bien sûr j'en ai fait les
frais c'est ça alors sonné au départ
c'était juste l'excellent à un camp vous
réguliers pas ses blagues
maintenant il le fait avec tout le monde
voyez quelque chose qui me contrarie
c'est insupportable parce que parce
qu'il a un regard tellement intense
depuis quitté comédiens regarder quand
mathieu va le chambrer ses trophées du
journaliste qui a du mal à faire son
duplex
regardez les nommer michel mr
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il devrait être a priori
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me rends
soit
[Applaudissements]
enregistrer un passager ont surpris
s'est pas présenté à la recherche samedi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya encore du boulot pour maximum en
même temps je comprends que jean michel
sapin un peu sur les dents quand on se
moque de lui car si on a bien un qui
bosse dans cette équipe
les gens me voient les bons chiffres
toujours les bogies de bons chiffres
mais pas les chiffres d'audience en lice
qui l'obsède c'est les chiffres du temps
qui reste avant la fin de l'émission non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a tenu quand même une semaine cette
banale à arriver ça continue encore mais
à un moment ça va se voir que tu bosses
pas à aller chercher vu ça y est un peu
trop et cyril hanouna 1 1 mais qui
regarde tous les week-ends l'intégrale
de columbo niveau enquête le mec il est
au top là il voit quelqu'un et le scan
il voit tout de suite si la personne
l'immense ça passionnant
tayrac tout de suite ouais on recevait
le rappeur nap's et son équipe
[Musique]
ils travaillent avec moi lui ces
chanteurs et chanteuses temps à l'équipe
et clippers qui est passé le petit coup
d'oeil il n'y a pas un gars calme prénom
normale maillot tu t'appelles vraiment
clippers walid timon wani s'appelle
clippers qui perd aussi un seul est quoi
mais tu aimes bien il ya deux clippers
maiana parce que faire tu m'aurais dit
il ya de chance vu que voulez vous
recherchez
[Applaudissements]
m
alors
[Applaudissements]
ça pourquoi faire des clés c'est
beaucoup et comme golfeur
quand je pense que pendant longtemps aux
écoutes notre prénom à tous était
chroniqueur c'est fort ayalon qui
comprend rien gaïa pas compris il a rien
compris qu est ce qu elles sont michel
va chercher mesdames d'american pie
c'est comment on viendrait à législatif
leur way est arrivé steffler c'est ça
s'ils flirtent chaleur stif leur jeu
voir si bush après le fou rire de la
semaine maintenant
qui dit fou rire dit évidemment benjamin
castaldi lui le mec qui vient dans
l'émission juste pour se marrer
il peut partir très vite là vous allez
voir il va décoller en une seconde à
cause d'un reportage sur les ex tard de
télé réalité alors je sais pas ce qu'il
a compris dans le témoignage de diana de
l'île de la tentation 1 6 mais ça va
tuer commercial dans l'immobilier
aujourd'hui je vis de ce qui rentre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est coauteur d'une obscure en
écoutant l'adorent fait on passe au top
j'ai danse à cette compilation des
petits moments insolites de tpm p
j'adore me non johnny hallyday nefa
testament faveur 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coc
ma foi
[Musique]
ce
je
bonjour monsieur rizzoli c
étant donné la bonne réponse il faut que
j'arrive à faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a pas mal
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
eh ben vous étrangler
voici reste à la bouche par an
[Musique]
c'est un tas mais c'est le truc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean rejoint gilles sur un seul point
c'est vrai qu'il avait déjà remarqué
qu'il y avait un esprit de fête qui
était beaucoup moins important que les
dépassant tu as le sentiment d'unité
beaucoup moins ça reste un super saut 17
chansons bien apprêtée nous faudra mais
sont assez variés après le gros bémol
c'est l'esprit qui est ce qu on avait
besoin de ça je ne peux franck dubosc
cartonne et je pense qu'il va revenir le
voir parce que ça va bientôt passer le
million le film on peut pas re voir
juste isabelle brunet 6e presse la règle
sont 2011 johnny hallyday nsa testament
faveur 2
[Applaudissements]
on a d'autres choses vous allez rendre à
d'autres choses la semaine dernière un
des moments les plus forts de l'émission
a bien évidemment été la mise au point
sentiments tels de kelly par rapport à
entonner une une affaire qui fait la une
de toutes les éditions des chaînes
d'info pendant plusieurs jours je
rappelle d'abord la vérité demande à
abbas eut aussi parce que c'est pas trop
de plaisir d'un seul coup parce que je
suis désolé pour la chaîne de l'info
kelly aller chez nous alors le scoop
c'est nous qui l'avons eu
pour ceux qui auraient manqué ce grand
moment un résumé complet de la faire
[Musique]
tout commence le 17 décembre 2017 quand
anthony entre en contact avec la djette
via un célèbre réseau social
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé que c'était très délire
entre nous voilà j'ai pas eu d'atomes
crochus avec lui content que je les ai
and follow de instagram web aura une
raison je suis pas seul et rouge
[Musique]
c'était c'était sur wii
mais alors vous étiez en chine had et
puis finalement vous êtes dynamique de
la vérité de demain
bon je crois que tu as la toile mais non
mais non
surtout qu'il faut se calmer a été tout
espérer de marmande est plus dans la rue
s'il ya moyen avec kelly kelly elle est
en mains joue au chat et à la souris
avec maxime et c'est plié fin du game
kelly plus maxime égale amour éternel
un récent divorce en divorce à son
devoir non mais ils se cachent même plus
les deux là bas je vais sur c'est gênant
pour tout le monde il est des moments
dans l'envié d'en jeter un seau d'eau
[Rires]
crise et personne n'a vu sérieuses à ces
pages vues sur le plateau a ouais parce
que vous vous arrêter aux évidences king
kenny maxime c'est comme les comédies
romantiques
au début tu as l'impression que ça
marchera jamais mais si tu regardes bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
souvent les mains
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dracula attendais pas je vais l'appeler
grogne à la paix dit radine en soit
voilà travail à la réalité non mais
c'est ça qui est bien fait l'ouvreur
sait plus quoi faire
en tout cas vous êtes plus je sais donc
vous êtes plus présent dans les quatre
tirs que dans l'émission j'ai
l'impression non mais c'est vrai je peux
venir qu'au pub si vous l'avez un peu
plus je vous mets quand même oui et on
commence par jean michel maire qui une
nouvelle fois à bugger vous savez quand
il répète 52 fait la même chose sans se
lasser on adore là et regarder des
extraits d'une caméra cachée degré
guillotin
dieu
5-4
[Musique]
cette vidéo dans ses vidéos ses vidéos
là je suis c'est bien parce que bon le
mec en face du monde mais j'ai peur je
m'en faire demi-tour
[Musique]
cyril vous appelez qui place notre
message appelait qui pour passez moi
l'autre compte commissariat expliqué me
charrière l'autre con je vois jouer sur
une pièce comme un monologue où quelque
chose qu'on a sûrement pas non non non
c'est le silence du vagin rhodia qui
m'envahissait m que c'est bon comme des
personnes quand des personnes âgées
s'énerve les plus âgés que moi
dominicains oh non non non mais non ça
sera encore au japon c'est bon d'être
devenu le quad est en vie
[Musique]
alors il est très mignon lui vaut
hashtag puceau
histoire d'assurer des débouchés clés
mais sans sourire non c'est bertrand
cantat qui a déclaré bertrand connaît
cantat qui dit j'ai payé la dette a
ajouté avant-hier ah ouais ça vous
l'avez acheté un banquier
[Musique]
et pour 12 mois
ouais ouais que jamais
qui a dénoncé qui te kelly mais remercie
kelly mais attention n'aime pas les
fayots ici enfin des gentils
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais toi tu cartonné et du jour au
lendemain tu as pu démissionner alors
aux moyens que sa guitare et study
lalanne est une blague c'est une blague
mais non mais tu commets une erreur
parce que c'est une règle tout ce qu'il
dit que des conneries mer et donc et
donc ces dites vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cinq mois après
est ce que ça contient on le sent et
parce qu'il approche sur la tête comme
ça jean-luc le brigand
[Applaudissements]